it is time for drew's news your daily
jump into the pile of good news leaves
and with me at the desk well he's a
crisp fall day in man form ross matthews
hi
in everybody form
well today we say goodbye to beauty week
oh we love beauty week it's okay
honestly every day for me i it's always
beauty week on this show and in my mind
um because it's so important and it
needs to be deep and meaningful and
coming from the right place with the
right messaging and on monday we had a
huge promise 100 beauty tips all week
long russ did we do it we're almost
there drew we're at 81 beauty tips
so we have
do the math
we have 19 more to go okay okay are we
gonna do it oh we're absolutely gonna
hit a hundred beauty tips all right well
i can do tip number 82 right now get it
okay so i would like to suggest
investing in a slip pillowcase mask um
they retail for usually somewhere under
thirty dollars and it's such an amazing
investment now silk doesn't pick up as
much poor clogging bacteria as cotton
does this is true we also did a story
about how often you're supposed to wash
your pillowcase it's way more than all
of us do yeah um but it's hypoallergenic
and it's resistant to dust mites
so that's helpful and disgusting okay
well i have tip number 83 if that's okay
give it to me now okay anyone ever have
a blemish yes oh god yeah here's a
little tip okay to get rid of it put a
little salt and warm water on a cotton
pad and then press it against the zit
and it will help dry it out and reduce
swelling and redness so if you don't
have all those fancy creams a little
salt water on a cotton swab yeah
i'll try it okay
you're welcome i love a big reveal and
speaking of reveals i've got one for you
ms barrymore right now
did you know that your book uh rebel
homemaker is now a new york times best
seller you are a best-selling
cookbook author
just announced
[Applause]
it's just it's so exciting and i'm just
relieved for the people who invested in
us they deserve their money back yes yes
and well done a great book
[Music]